it'll open the right doors some of the
wrong ones too well friends even after a
couple trailers the summer movie event
tenant is still a mystery in true
Christopher Nolan corn so we're gonna
break down everything we know about this
film right now on the catch-up tenant is
the follow-up to writer director
Christopher Nolan certified fresh'
Dunkirk and of course other hit films
like interstellar inception and the Dark
Knight trilogy and based on what we know
so far 10 it will be much more in line
with his time vending efforts like
Inception use it carefully the film is
an original story about a secret agent
on a mission to stop a potential world
war 3 while going up against a Russian
national bad guy but as we've seen in
the trailers with cars crashing in
Reverse and bullet holes in walls before
shots are fired this isn't your ordinary
spy thriller in fact this is Nolan's
most expensive original film ever with a
production budget of 205 million dollars
and he told total film magazine that
it's a film of great ambition and great
scale that takes a genre namely the spy
film and tries to take it into some new
territory
can we talk about that massive plane
crash though well how big a plane
and he appears to be doing this by
giving the lead character who's a newer
crew into some sort of agency played by
John David Washington the ability to
harness a mysterious power to reverse
time something he calls inversion in the
trailer how this is possible and what
this all means is still unclear but
Washington will be joining up with and
going up against a pretty impressive
cast to help pull it off and that starts
with Robert Pattinson who of course will
be starring in the Batman next year
along with Elizabeth debicki from
widow's Michael Caine who's no stranger
to Nolan films Aaron taylor-johnson from
Avengers age of Ultron and Kenneth
Branagh as the bad guy thank God
oh and it's worth noting that
cinematographer Hoyt van Hoyt Zuma who
worked with Nolan on interstellar and
Dunkirk is back behind the camera but
Hans Zimmer Nolan's long time go-to
composer was busy scoring Danny
Villeneuve's upcoming dune so instead he
went with Ludwig
göransson who's done the music for black
panther and the mandalorian and honestly
slayed the trailer soundtrack
now if you're wondering a tenant one of
the only major movies that hasn't
changed its release date due to the Cova
19 pandemic and still hit that July 17th
mark and come out in theaters you're not
alone what we do know is that Nolan is a
big fan of the movie-going experience
especially in the IMAX setting and he
gets 20% of the film's first dollar
gross so Nolan has his way one way or
another it seems that this film will be
hitting theaters before streaming from
your couch even becomes an option
time travel No all right friends it is
time for us to kick it over to you now
are you excited for Tennant and can you
handle Christopher Nolan's obsession
with bending time or are you just not
into it let us know all your thoughts
and feelings in the comment section and
for more streaming or movie news head on
over to Rotten Tomatoes comm also do not
forget to join our fan group on Facebook
so you can vote in our polls and open up
about your deepest darkest dreaming
habits and speaking of our fans here's a
special message from one of them what's
up world big shout out to MP from the
ketchup on Rotten Tomatoes I'm JK
Gonzalez reppin Chicago Illinois
I just wanna everybody to stay safe and
stay fresh and if you don't want to miss
out on any future episodes of this show
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always thank
you guys so much for watching the
ketchup we love you and we hope to see
you in the next video bye
[Music]